is it foolish to go back into debt yes
start a business yes you just called the
ramsy show JT you walked into the bear
cave and as the bear if it was
hungry what's the business uh my trade
or work is a I'm a 401k consultant I do
a risk of compliance I just kind of
start my own firm and it's a lot to try
to just bankroll why and why what do you
got a bankroll that's what I'm wondering
well that ought to cash flow you day one
well I mean everything from you know
software agreements all sorts of stuff
well what do you think it takes to get
this going why why have you decide what
you're describing to me you need a
computer and some sweat okay and a
customer yeah or six you are not ready
to open a business and leave your job
when you have absolutely no customers
you don't have a clue where your
customers are coming from you're not
ready to open a business and has nothing
to do with a loan